First of all welcome back.
It's so exciting to see so
many familiar faces.
Many of you don't look different
at all in the last five years,
so you look fantastic.
Let me just say that.
I also wanted to give you kind of
a road map of what we're going to do.
I'm going to talk a little bit about
why I'm happy to be here right now.
Friday night with you
guys without alcohol,
but I know it's outside and luring you.
So, I'm going to try and
make sure that this is sort of spiced up.
Then I'm going to talk a little bit
about the power of story in two regards.
The first is as an asset,
strategically for business.
Raise your hands if you've
founded your own company or
are working sort of at your own company
in some way, shape, or form, so
that's like I don't
know 25% of the people.
And how many of you have
been at a company that you
started with right when
you finished the GSV?
Raise your hands.
That's about 20%.
So, I'm going to be
asking both of you groups
of people a set of questions about sort of
thinking about story as a strategic asset.
Then I'm going to turn to this idea of
story as life, this idea that story may
be better than anything else in our life
both captures meaning and creates meaning.
So, and then I'm going to talk a little
bit about what I hope you do on Monday.
So first of all, before I dive in,
I wanted to lay out a framework
of some recent research that I've done
with Seth Cumber and Cassie Mogilner,
and this is based off of a data
set called We Feel Fine,
which Seth Cumber and
Jonathan Harris pulled together.
And the way to read this simple slide is,
which is, by the way,
essentially a summary of
over 10,000 data points over
three years time over,
across cultures, and it's blog based
data where Seth and Jonathan scrape
the blogosphere for all mentions of.
I feel and I am feeling.
And then they can co-vary what people
are feeling, and what they're saying,
doing, feeling, etc, when they're
talking about certain emotions.
Because blog based data has
demographics associated with it.
You can then start to better understand
sort of the emotional lexicon of
our lives.
So the way to read this slide
is we start out simple,
this is your 11 to 14 year old son,
daughter, nephew, niece, sibling who
when you say how are you you
feeling they say, how is your day?
What did you do today?
Exactly.
You know them.
You have them in your life.
But soon we fill up with angst, so
this is the 15 to 18 year olds
who feel a great deal of angst.
When they do feel happy,
it is equated with excitement.
Quite literally happiness and excitement
co-vary in a very significant way.
And it's not that they feel
excited all the time or
angsty all the time it's that the meaning
of happiness, the definition of happiness
is associated with excitement until
you leave those feelings, and
then started to feel more unknown,
confined, alone.
At 19, 20, 21, I started to feel
not well understood often times.
And then we started to feel that we
could conquer the world at 22 to 26.
And now we start to feel that
we actually have a goal.
That we know what we're doing.
The meaning of happiness starts to equate
with feeling proud or satisfied or
still excited before gradually
trading ambition for balance.
So at 30, we start to say we're
imbalanced, we forgot to have kids,
I stopped working out, oops, and so
the feeling of happiness is equated
with feeling aligned again.
Developing appreciation for
our physical bodies.
At 35, they've gone downhill in
a very systematic way, surprisingly.
We wake up and we're like wow,
how did that happen?
And our children,
an evolving sense of in which we feel
grateful, happy, calm, and then blessed.
And as some of you know with this data,
it is not that you die at 55.
It's that there is just not
the rich emotional lexicon.
And I also actually, this is actually
12 million data points on 10 thousand.
So this is 12 million data points
worldwide, so it is a very,
very large data set to help unpack
the emotional lexicon of our lives.
So what we've done with this,
is we've started to say if this
is the story of our lives.
And if this is, in fact,
the story of the lives of our customers.
So, even if you've captured strong
value through your customer,
this research would suggest that
the value propositions going to shift in
pre-systematic ways every 5 or 10 years,
and it's the story of our employees.
So, even if again your employee set
is incredibly happy, this research
would suggest that in 5 or 10 years
they're going to be shifting again.
So, the way to think about this,
and it's not just across your life,
this is sort of the story of a project or
even a day you get here for
the alumni weekend, and you have again
this sort of story that's unfolding.
I'd be really curious.
I invite anyone to actually tell me
at the end of this reunion weekend,
and just email me, @stanford,
what was the story of the weekend?
What's the story that you actually
are going to tell your friends,
family, whatever about this weekend?
You're not going to say like I went
on Friday and I told Jennifer,
and then I went on Saturday and
I saw my friends.
You're not going to do that.
You're going to tell a story and
that's the way you're going
to remember this experience.
So, you start out with discovery.
You know, as we are at this moment
where you don't really know your goals.
You don't really know what's going to
happen and the meaning of happiness,
again, is about excitement.
Then you move to pursuit, so you might
know your goals, you want to try and
talk to a few people or
be able to connect.
And there, the feeling is I'm
feeling like I'm winning, or
I'm conquering the world or
at least I know what I'm doing.
And then you move to balance and you say
how can I align my friends, my family,
my work, my health, and then you
move to impact where you wake up and
you say man I've been so focused or
focused on my family, but
really what is my impact in the world, and
what is the pro social benefit
that I want to be able to create
with a meaning of happiness is much more
associated with feeling significant.
And then you move to savoring
where instead of being more
forward looking you're
more present oriented,
and the meaning of happiness is associated
with feeling content in the here and now.
And how many of you know individuals that,
and again it's not just over your life,
there's some individuals that just
feel very content and savoring even if
they're 18 and conversely there's 55 Five
year olds who are excited all of the time.
And in fact, we have research to show that
if we give 18 year olds the task to
breathe deeply, focused on the present.
Like pretend you guys do,
in fact, do it all now.
Breathe deeply.
Focus on the present.
You guys breathe normal.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, keep it up for the whole talk.
I, it's incredibly hard to do, but I
can't begin to tell you the physiological
benefit that it will actually give you,
so I challenge you to do that.
And then these 18 year olds,
breath normally, and
we come back and
we ask them two very different questions.
You know, what is the meaning of happiness
and you guys define it as Excitement,
there's one person listening.
I love you, fantastic.
[LAUGH]
>> And then you guys,
after breathing deeply, focused on
the present and feeling very connected,
actually define happiness as
contentment like a 55 year old would.
So for various, sort of,
with five minutes.
A deep breathing focused on the present
in a more meditative state.
You can actually change your mindset.
In fact, we give you guys choices like
do you want a peppermint refreshing tea.
And you are more likely to pick the
peppermint refreshing tea because often we
make choices based on our definition
of happiness or how to optimize.
Whereas you are much more likely to
choose a tea that's very peaceful and
calming like chamomile.
So, the point here being that our meaning
of happiness changes over the life course,
over a project, and even within the day
as something as small as five minutes.
Now this research was really exciting for
me and I'll start to explain why.
The first is that it shows that even
though most people believe that
happiness is either one thing.
Or in fact it's individual,
so all whatever,
300 people here have a unique
definition of happiness.
This research suggests that happiness and
its meaning changes in very systematic
ways, all the way from excitement
to essentially contentment.
And the second insight is that
what people are valuing and
what they're searching for
is really different.
So what we find is at 18,
we're often valuing
this notion of I just want to feel happy,
and for me that's excitement.
And at age 30, 40, 50,
you're starting to feel like,
I just want to feel like I
have meaning in my life.
That feeling of fulfillment.
That feeling of joy and contentment.
And so what people are optimizing for, and
making choices based on,
is a really different utility function.
Now these two things, happiness
versus meaning, are often equated.
In fact, 40% to 50% of the variance in
these two constructs are both positive.
So it's hard to kind of unpack them.
But we've done that, to some degree.
And if anyone's interested,
just Google happiness versus meaning, and
you can dive into the data.
But I wanted to summarize
the differences between these
two very positive constructs.
Because it has a lot to do with my premise
which is I hope you start leading lives
that are filled with stories to a much
greater degree than you are so far.
So the first difference
between chasing happiness or
living a life based on this idea
of valuing or searching for
happiness, versus meaning is
that happiness feels good.
So if you ask people, listen,
how happy are you and
to what degree do you feel like
you have a meaningful life?
And then people obviously have
different ratings on a 1.7 scale.
You can start to partial out the positive
covariance in those two things.
And we can start to peel apart those
individuals who feel very happy,
but don't feel like they
have a lot of meaning.
And individuals that feel like they have a
lot of meaning, but not necessarily happy.
So in that way, we can start to see that
happiness is about really feeling good,
and meaningfulness does too,
but not always.
So there's a lot of low points.
Anxiety, fear, etc.,
wrapped up in feeling meaning.
There's a lot of ups.
There's a lot of downs.
It's a roller coaster.
So if you think about it from a story
structure perspective, it's not winning,
winning, winning, winning.
It's winning, losing,
winning, trying, winning.
There's an arc to the life of meaning.
The second is that happiness
is more focused on yourself.
People that claim to be very happy but
not a lot of meaning
self-rate themselves as being [LAUGH]
self-focused and more egocentric.
The individuals that say that they have
a lot of meaning that maybe are less happy
are very anchored on others.
Giving to others,
feeling connected to others.
And the third and last difference is that
happiness is about how you feel now, and
meaningfulness is about the past,
the present, and the future.
It's much more lasting.
So these are three of maybe the more
important differences between meaning,
but it's really hard to ask yourself well,
I'm going to go out and
have a meaningful day, or
where's meaning found.
And the contention would be that meaning
is both captured and created in?
A second person I love!
Awesome!
Okay, you saw where I was going with this.
So stories, all right, so what is a story?
Three ways to define it.
It's marked by ups and
downs, highs and lows,
it's a narrative with a beginning and
a middle and an end.
And again it's not just winning, winning,
winning, there's no tension there,
there's no evolution,
it's actually an arc.
So if you start to think about
James Bond films, right.
Wow, what happened?
I don't know.
He gets the girl.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The arc if very clear and
it's repeated again and again and again,
or Jurassic Park, nothing going on, T-Rex!
Nothing going on.
Big T-Rex!
Really really big T-Rex!
So it's not a sophisticated arc but
it's still an arc.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or Casablanca where there's micro or
minis or stories that have arcs
that echo the overall story arc.
The second thing that pulls apart story
from just a list of facts, or features, or
a to do list,
is that it's typically human centered.
There's a protagonist, and
there's characters, and
there's the mix between both of them.
Many of you know the six word story
written by Ernest Hemingway, who said,
baby shoes for sale, never worn.
And we don't know if that's a young
couple who couldn't have a baby,
or the baby didn't make it.
But we do know something about that story.
And neurologically, what's happening
when you share a story versus just
say there was a young couple and
they couldn't have a baby.
Is that the person listening to the story
is making the inference about the story.
And when people make
the inference about the story
it stays in their mind because it's
being processed by both hemispheres.
Versus when I just share
something to you where
you don't have to make the inference
because I'm telling it to you.
You don't have to process that
information nearly as deeply.
So it's giving people two plus two and
they are inferring the four,
instead of just giving them four.
So, how many of you have
been in one of my classes?
My God, 40%.
All right, so
you've probably have done this, but
it's really fun to do it a second time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So your.
>> You're going to.
So I made my students always share
six word stories about their life.
Here's a couple more recent ones.
Not quite, aspiring to be quite.
Tonight, he packs.
Tomorrow, I pine.
Married the wrong girl.
Fixed it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And getting old ringtones piss me off.
>> So, I'm going to have you write,
of course, a six word story.
You can put it in your iPhone,
or your cell phone, or.
I encourage you to take out
a piece of paper if you can and
I'm going to have you write a six-word
story about your Stanford experience.
So whenever you were here, what was the
story of your life, when you were here?
And I'm going to have you share, so I'm
going to give you 30 seconds to write it.
And remember, think of a change.
Remember, think of how you changed maybe.
It's a good little tip.
I encourage you to make it funny
if you have a sense of humor.
And if you don't, still make it funny.
And you're going to share it with
the two or three people next to you.
So you have 30 seconds.
Go ahead, write it, or think it.
Okay, finishing up?
All right, you're going to grab the two or
three people next to you, and
you are going to share
your six word story.
And you have one minute
to complete all of it.
All right?
Ready, set, go!
>> All right.
All right.
Coming back.
>> [LAUGH]
>> All right,
I want to see if any of you
want to nominate one of
the people you just talked
to that had an epic story.
Raise your hand.
Raise your hand, I want a couple of
volunteers who had a great story.
All right, there's one there,
you're going to come up to the podium.
Okay, guy next to the gal
who's pointing vigorously.
>> [LAUGH]
>> All right, that guy, second, third,
and fourth, and fifth, okay?
So we have five and awesome,
you're going to come up to the microphone
because I guess we're live streamed.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
everybody in Bangladesh is
going to know what I say?
>> Bangladesh is going to love your story.
All right, say your name and
then your six word story.
Greg Lamps and it's the best
$100,000 dating service.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> What a deal, what a deal.
The best $100,000 dating service.
Go ahead.
>> Hi, I'm Stephanie.
>> Stephanie.
>> Do I belong here?
Yes, wow a little bit sweeter but
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> These are a little hard to follow.
Betsy Parker met great people,
met myself finally.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> She also is very efficient with words,
so that's five words.
You got an extra word.
>> So DDA.
Old change except for the accent.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> All right.
I think last one.
Is there one more?
Okay.
>> Adrian Lee.
Wrong girl.
Wrong job.
Right school.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> All right.
So the last thing I'm going to leave you
with is moving forward into this weekend,
really, again, open invitation.
Please send me your six word
stories of what happened,
what you hope happens this weekend and
then also what did.
The last component of stories is that it
lasts over time from a neurological angle
goal as well as something that
does last actually over time.
So let me talk a little bit about, let's
see if the volume's on the sciences story.
>> Once upon a time
information was scarce, so
we made decisions based
on advise of experts.
Using them as North Stars for instance.
Now, thanks to the internet, we can
ourselves try and find our own answers to
questions that plague us, and find
information to make informed decisions.
But instead of finding clear answers,
we often find noise.
We're living in a world where
we have too much information.
And because of that, we're even
more susceptible to great story.
>> It's what helps us
decide what to believe in.
Stories are important because they're
meaningful, and they are meaningful
because they're memorable, impactful,
and they personally connect.
First, let's talk about memorability.
Eugene O'Kelly was a CEO
of a consulting company.
He started having headaches.
He was referred to a top neurosurgeon in
New York where he was diagnosed with late
stage brain cancer, and
he was given three months to live.
He started talking to his wife.
How does he want to spend
those hundred days?
He was purposeful about who he spent time
with, and what stories to share with them.
He also thought hard about what would be
remembered in those last hundred days.
He and his wife would live each day
with a focus on finding perfect moments
where time expands and
when noise is separated from signal.
All that exists is that single moment.
And he found in those perfect
moments those were the most
memorable stories that defined his life.
In one study researchers asked
students to make a one minute
persuasive pitch to other
members in their class.
And on average a typical student
used 2.5 statistics in their pitch.
Only 1 in 10 told a story.
10 minutes later, the researcher asked
everyone to pull out a sheet of paper, and
write down every single
idea they remembered.
Only 5% remembered any statistic,
63% of the students remembered the story.
Stories are memorable in
a way that statistics aren't.
Now let me talk about impact.
Research shows that individuals
are more likely to buy from a person or
an organization whose story they believe
in and which resonates with them.
In one study Deb Small at
the University of Pennsylvania and
her colleagues wanted to determine how to
best raise money for Save the Children.
A charity focused on the well-being
of children worldwide.
We created two versions
of a marketing pamphlet.
The first version features statistics
about the magnitude of problems
facing children in Africa.
The second version also
featured those statistics, but
in addition, provided information about
Rokia, a seven year old girl from Mali.
Who face the threat of severe hunger.
The subjects were given $5 as compensation
for the study, and before leaving,
the researches asked if they wanted
to donate any money to the cause.
The individuals in the story condition
gave nearly twice as much money as
those in the statistics condition.
We used to think it was our rational
brain that makes decisions.
Now we know it's emotion
driving decisions and
we rationalize the decision afterwards.
Finally, I want to talk
about personal connection.
Research shows that if you present
statistics to an audience, a certain part
of the brain called the Broca's and
Wernicke's area gets activated.
So the language processing part
of the brain is activated and
we can understand but not feel.
When a story is shared,
the audience feels the story.
Our whole brain is activated.
The meaning is extracted.
The meaning of the story comes from
the personal connection the audience feels
when they're listening to the story.
And when a story is well-told,
they're able to feel connected,
not just to the story but
to the storyteller.
When most of us think of advocating for
ideas, we go to statistics.
We go to convincing arguments, facts, and
figures, but studies show that if we share
a story, people are more likely to
remember the message, be persuaded by it,
feel personally connected to it.
And when data and
stories are used together,
audiences are moved both
intellectually and emotionally.
For lasting effect, you need to
persuade the rational brain, but
also resonate with the emotional brain.
Recent behavioral research has
shown why stories are so powerful,
it's because they are meaningful.
Those who tell the best stories
will become the best leaders.
If we consider the simple question,
what is the story or why am I doing this,
we may finally make very different
choices at how we spend our time.
Isabel Allende once wrote, silence
before being born, silence after death.
Life is nothing but noise between
those two unfathomable silences.
But there is signal and there is noise and
how we reduce the noise?
Story.
>> Pretty awesome!
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Just joking.
So story is awesome.
Let me just go through the three types
of qualities that companies that
harness story well do.
They tend to harness story
in a way that really designs
story with authenticity,
empathy, and purpose.
So, first, design for authenticity.
When you share a story, if you're a CEO,
you're starting a company,
you're trying to recruit, retain so
you need to feel authentic.
Research by Body shows that people can
tell within milliseconds of meeting
you whether they trust you, like you,
whether you're authentic, and
that type of science applies when
you're especially sharing stories.
And both customers and employees need to
believe your story and be inspired by it.
And what's happening right now
in the world is that brands and
organizations and companies often
feel manufactured but people don't.
So one of the reasons story's
become this kind of bigger thing or
this notion of people as brands has become
a bigger thing is partly because of that
deep desire to have authenticity and
trust in our relationships.
>> Hi.
I'm Mike.
Founder of DollarShaveClub.com.
What is DollarShaveClub.com?
Well, for a dollar a month we send high
quality razors right to your door.
Yeah, a dollar.
Are the blades any good?
No.
Our blades are fucking great.
Each razor has stainless steel blades
an aloe vera lubricating strip, and
a pivot head.
It's so gentle a toddler could use it.
And do you like spending $20
a month on brand name razors?
$19 go to Roger Fedderer.
I'm good at tennis.
And do you think your razor needs
a vibrating handle, a flashlight,
a back scratcher, and ten blades?
[SOUND] Your handsome ass
grandfather had one blade and polio.
Looking good, Pop Pop.
Stop paying for shave tech you don't need.
And stop forgetting to buy
your blades every month.
Alejandra and
I are going to ship them right to you.
[SOUND]
>> [LAUGH]
>> We're not just selling razors,
we're also making new jobs.
Alejandra, what were you doing last month?
>> Not working.
>> What are you doing now?
>> Working.
>> I'm no Vanderbilt, but
this train makes hay.
[SOUND]
>> [LAUGH]
>> So stop forgetting to buy your
blades every month, and start deciding
where you're going to stack all those
dollar bills that I'm saving you.
We are DollarShaveClub.com,
and the party is on.
[MUSIC]
>> My favorite part is Alejandra,
she just looks so embarrassed.
>> [LAUGH]
>> There's a lot of
companies that are here
in the room right now.
Raise your hand if you're
from Manchester United.
You might, like a good Australian,
be drinking alcohol already.
So I'm not sure, but, or English, right?
Anyway.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm not a big sports guy, but word,
on the street is that
Manchester United people
really are authentically sports people.
A second, incredibly authentic
brand is Phil's, right?
How many of you drink Phil's?
So the authenticity that
comes with the barista and
everything about Phil's
just oozes authenticity.
The second thing that strong brands that
harness story well do is they design for
empathy so it is not all about them.
They know that brands too often try
to be the hero of their story but
more often than not,
customers are the hero.
And that has gone into Twitter,
who has done a really good job
at least of documenting some of
the stories of ordinary people
harnessing Twitter or Facebook or
YouTube in ways that make those
platforms clear in terms of its value.
And some you have already enjoyed this but
Google,
which has really struggled from
a marketing perspective because they won't
talk about themselves and if you hire
a whole bunch of smart people and
they just actually make great products,
the products should sell.
So when Google Chrome did not get adopted,
it was not being used to the degree that
Google thought they should,
they had a real problem because if they
don't believe in marketing how
are they going to get adoption?
And their answer to that
question was story.
[MUSIC]
>> Are you ready for your big party today?
>> [LAUGH] [NOISE]
[MUSIC]
[NOISE]
>> So that single ad, which then
led to Superbowl ads and whatnot,
was in fact the reason why
Google Chrome started getting adopted.
And it wasn't just a focus on
Google Chrome, it was really a focus on
Daniel Lee, this idea of deep empathy
being a way of telling the story,
where Google Chrome is just enabling
Daniel Lee to be a great dad, and in fact,
makes us all want to go have kids again,
because we forgot to do
everything that Daniel Lee did.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Damn, could of had more kids.
So Kitchet, I think, has done
a really good job around designing
around empathy and
really understanding what that user wants.
I think also MasterClass has
done a really remarkable job by
David Rogier to say you know,
we want to democratize learning and
the ability to actually create skills
around story, writing, tennis.
And we're going to do
it in affordable ways.
And I think also Sequoia Creative
they've done a really good job
from a venture perspective.
A better understanding,
not just their CEO's, but
the users of the CEO's products and
unlocking that story.
Third and last, a design for purpose.
This notion that Tom's and
Moby Parker and Body Shop or Ben &
Jerry's all of these companies that have
In their core what the larger mission, or
the larger inspired mission is starting,
but slowly I think especially
here at Stanford to get baked in in
a deeper way in business models.
And you see people like Ben Horowitz
say things like the company's story is
the company's strategy.
The story must explain why you exist,
why we're doing this.
Why does the problem need to be solved?
Why should you join the company?
Why should you invest in in?
Why should you buy a product from it?
So all of these things if the story is
not well told, if it doesn't come across.
The answers to these questions will be no.
The thing that's important here is that
people want to be valued members of
a winning team on an inspired mission and
if you get any one of these words wrong,
that's when you lose momentum,
productivity, performance.
And maybe the most important word or
two in the sentence is the inspired
mission to what degree do you feel
connected to something bigger?
Something bigger that your team is
enabling, your company is enabling, and
you're feeling connected to the world
because as the meaning of happiness shifts
in these systematic ways and you move from
feeling excitement to wanting money and
status.
To wanting some element of balance,
you will need that desire for impact and
significance.
I think Mystree's really done a remarkable
job if you dive into their website,
and you understand their business model,
they've done purpose in a really
clever and authentic way.
I think Levo League has done it,
as well as Amour Vert.
Lastly I wanted to mention I think stories
are important not just as an asset for
companies and leaders, but also in life.
So some of you guys know
that I have three kids.
And they're now 14, 14, and 10.
And story as a scientist
trained to disregard story,
literally told that some us the story
you will not pay attention to it,
certainly you want to make
a decision base on it.
So, it's been really an actually
interesting last five years
where story was shared immediate
fundamentally change my life because
I was wanted to be an oncologist.
And, there was a time
where I would try and
train in terms of medicine, and realized,
I'm not going to be the mom I want to be.
I'm going to end up being a professor.
And, the reason I chose to
be a professor was because I
really wanted to be this great mom.
And also, a great wife and
a great friend, to my family.
And so, that was the, really the impetus,
to be a marketing professor.
But I have to tell you a secret.
Just among the whatever,
300+ live stream of us.
I don't even like marketing, so
I might not even like business.
So I'm finding myself as
a marketing professor at
a business school partly because my dad,
raise your hand, Dad.
Yep.
There you go.
Say hi everyone.
Hi everyone.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Partly because
my dad was such a phenomenal father and
I saw my father who's a professor
just be remarkable and
he raised us with stories,
he would take us on special days where my
two sisters and I would get to go out with
my father and he would take us, basically,
which where he wanted to go And
we would never want to go, but
he called it a special day.
And so therefore we were so excited.
And when they would take pictures and
then we would remember it,
and we would anticipate it as special,
we would remember it as special.
And even if we had a horrible
time at the cow game or
whatever it was, we did not remember and
we did not anticipate to remember.
And that way of living.
That way of raising us as kids
based on story became incredibly
incredibly important to me.
Such that I made a career
decision to be a professor.
And hopefully be that parent and
partner that I had seen in my family.
And so
that was kind of the context of living.
Story as a way of living certainly
infiltrated the way I was brought up,
and it's impacted the way
we've raised our kids, and
I wanted to share two anecdotes with you.
The first is the way,
I have to get into marriage therapy,
but the way my husband and
I actually relate
It's fundamentally different
because of a story shared with me.
To give you a little bit of
background on my husband,
Andy Smith, who's a venture capitalist,
at the time, maybe five or
6 years ago or a little bit more,
he was running global brands at Dolby.
And was really enamored with technology,
IOT, social media, etc.
I thought social media was complete
crap and was so skeptical that
we would really argue at the dinner table.
Even in front of our kids.
What did you do today?
I created a social media strategy for
Dole Band and
I'd say that seems like a waste of time.
They're a business to business brand.
And he'd say you're a marketing
professor at Standford and
you've never been on Facebook.
That doesn't seem smart.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
whenever we disagree I usually
run a study to see if I'm right.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
I asked a hundred people representative
of the United States what they thought of
social media and about 50% of
them said very positive words and
the other 50 or so percent of them
again said a lot of negative words,
which at least made me feel vindicated.
So you know in this belief
that social media was
completely destroying
the world at that time, and
remember I'm heads down publishing
my papers, analysing big data sets,
and sort of disagreeing
with Andy on a few things.
But I was teaching this creativity and
innovation class,
and one of my students,
Robert who some of you might know,
shared with me a story at the end of
the class of how the class impacted him.
And he shared the story of Sameer, his
best friend here, a Stanford undergrad,
who went off and created his own company,
just like 20% of you.
And got married.
Fell in love with Rena and
was diagnosed with leukemia
while they were traveling in India and
he was shocked.
Called Robert and Robert was shocked and
asked their friend network what they
should be doing and they learned that
another friend of theirs, here and
Fremont was also recently
diagnosed with leukemia, and
many of you know this data, but
I will just share it with you in silence.
So Robert wrote a story about Sameer and
that story about Sameer and
those first two paragraphs was so clear,
that if anyone got this email
they felt like they knew him.
You're so often asked to do things but
without a story you're not
compelled to read or act.
And then the clear call to action,
please get registered.
Spread the word and learn more.
Come to these websites and they took that
simple story with a call to action and
they harnessed social media and
Robert reversed the rules.
He did things in very unexpected ways.
He didn't just build up the story and
put it on a website and
share it via social media channels.
They actually created two organizations,
team Vinay and Team Sameer and
used Google Docs and
other tools to be able to communicate.
These instant websites were
also clear calls to action,
where if you double clicked any of
the links, up came an essentially
a dragonfly type of model where any
of these links off of the website.
So if you were here at Stanford and
you wanted to run a corporate drive,
up would come a bone marrow drive to work,
a dummies guide and,
all of these links are live.
So, if you double click the text in red,
up comes a letter.
Dear Garth,
I want to run a bone marrow drive here,
this Friday, on alumni weekend.
This is what we need to do, cut, paste,
send and even a thank you letter.
We ran a drive last Friday,
we got 200 people in.
Thank you very much.
This is what we need to do next cut,
paste, send.
So that social change in a box, made that
story ignite in very significant ways.
And many of you know, people acted.
They created Facebook ads,
and YouTube videos, and
shared it on their own social
media channels and through that,
the result in 11 weeks was
470 bone marrow drives run.
Nearly 25,000 South Asians registered,
and in that time,
Sameer found a perfect match,
and Vinay found a good match.
Sameer now shared his story, even though
he was sort of private about this all
because he wanted to raise venture
money and he did not want this out.
And he wanted it to be private but
once 25,000 people acted for
him, he wanted open up.
He started blogging.
He shared that story.
And he started appreciating
life in a very meaningful way.
Not in a happy, excited way,
but in a deeply meaningful way.
In a way that talked a lot about
significance a lot about savoring a lot
about others and appreciation and
it wasn't winning, winning, winning.
It was hard, it was winning and
losing and being scared, and
wanting something and feeling grateful for
what others had done.
He even put his bone marrow
registry onto YouTube so
that in future years people could
see that actually giving and
receiving bone marrow is not
nearly as difficult as you think.
And the lessons they learned was
that power of a single focused goal,
20,000 south Asians in the registry.
The power of reversing the rules,
doing things in very unexpected ways, and
grabbing attention.
And how do you tell a good and
truthful story,
because otherwise people simply won't act.
And then, how do you design for
the network, allowing everyone to,
in fact, contribute and
choose their own weapon.
Sameer, though, relapsed within
three months of of his transplant,
at the end of my class and
that was him two days before with Reena.
We celebrated his life by sharing
a memorial service in the world, so
a global wide webcast with
6,000 people participating.
Vinay also had a successful transplant but
he also relapsed a few months after
Sameer and he passed on in June.
But the purpose revealed,
as 40% of you here know,
is that 266 people were
matched in one year alone.
And that is 266 people that don't
just have the gift of hope, but
the gift of time, because odds of survival
go up from 40% to 80% if you find
a perfect match immediately.
And the final thoughts is that most
revolutions are sparked by the actions of
the few, and
your biggest asset is a clear mind and
a large idea to find that
ignition point and light it.
And as I was listening to Robert's story,
Robert, just like you, my students sitting
in a seat just like yours sharing
a story that just made me sob.
All I could think about
is what would I do now,
could I water the story, would the story
grow, how would that make me feel and
all I could think about was
that would make me happy.
So I talked to Andy that night and
I said, what could we do to help?
I admitted that social media
had some redeeming feature.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And we started interviewing people,
people that harness social networks,
harness story.
To significant in fact, and we found
that all of them did these four things.
All of them had a single focus goal,
not two, not three, but a single one.
They all grabbed attention and
reversed the rules,
did things in very unexpected ways.
They all engaged and
were anchored on audience,
creating authentic, relevant content.
And they all enabled action,
this idea design for
the network versus an individual
defined all of their movements.
So that story well-told
created 470 bone marrow drives
all across the United States.
And then,
it lead us to basically right this book,
The Dragonfly Effect,
which I didn't ever want to write.
But it just kind of, I felt like
Sameer was writing it for us and
then, it allowed,
I used to work with 100,000 sheiks.
These 12 students here at Stanford who,
in honor and legacy of Sameer and Vinay,
got over 113,000 people in
the bone marrow registry,
in one year alone harnessing
social networks and story.
And that led to OpenIDEO participating and
co-creating a design challenge
to electrify and ignite over
a million people internationally.
Which led to at least one match of
Amit Gupta with his friends and family and
network who is alive and healthy
today when diagnosed with leukemia.
We found a match and that makes me happy.
And it makes me happy
in a way that's very,
very anchored on connectedness and
gratefulness and blessedness and
I think all of us have closet careers and
all of us like maybe being an oncologist.
And this opportunity for you to be
back here at your reunion in the space
of potentially thinking of that six
word story that defined your time here.
And then,
thinking about your next chapter,
what do you want that
six word story to be and
to what degree do you want to have a very
different definition of happiness?
To what degree do you want to search or
chase different things and
might be create legacy for you?
So, what to do on Monday?
Three things, I hope you continue to think
of story as an asset for your company and
design with authenticity,
empathy and purpose.
I hope you've continue to
think of story as life.
With our three kids we now ask over
the dinner table what was the story of
the day because it turns out when you ask
what did you do today, you get nothing.
But when you ask them to share just one
story, it can be funny, it can be sad,
it can be anything.
They will lead to conversations
that are much richer, and
your relationship will be much
richer at least, it was with ours.
Stories can clarify our past and
they can guide our future stories
create and capture meaning.
So bank your stories just like you
did with me, in 30 seconds and
you'll find that the most important
stories that define your past and
will indicate your future are those
that are indeed personal, distinct,
relevant, memorable they
depict something larger.
They create legacy, so in conclusion,
tell me the facts and I'll learn.
Tell me the truth and
I'll believe but tell me a story and
it will live in my heart forever.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]